i am like you know deeply protective
over my family
she's gonna get sued for that plain and
simple i i don't play games with that
kind of stuff
the battle is on between conservative
pundit
candice owens and cardi b when i say
something like she's toxic to culture
the reason she gets so worked up and she
starts spiraling is because she knows
it's real
it all started on monday when candace
appeared on fox news
and criticized cardi and megan the
stallion's performance of their hit
single [ __ ] at sunday's grammy awards you
see that fundamentally we are seeing the
destruction of american values american
principles
and it's terrifying i think parents
should be terrified that this is the
direction that our society is heading
towards and again
we are weakening america that's really
what we should be talking about this is
a weakening
of american society we are setting the
stage and it feels like
we are looking at corrosion like we are
about to see the end of an
empire well cardi shared that clip on
twitter writing
yay we made fox news guys [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
she added quote matter of fact i'm just
going to thank candy owens
she put my performance on fox news
giving it more views that boosted the
views on youtube
and is counting towards my streams and
sales
oh snappity-snap snap but things quickly
went downhill
after cardi shared an alleged tweet from
owens claiming the political
commentator's husband had cheated on her
with owen's brother
the author initially laughed off the
tweet writing quote
i am literally laughing out loud cardi
my dear that is clearly a photoshop
tweet
only one of us has a husband that sleeps
around but
later added that she is 100 suing cardi
adding you can't just start throwing out
wild lies against
private members of my family because
you're upset someone called you out on
your degenerate performance
she shares this photoshopped tweet
and that says that my husband had an
affair with my brother
completely wild completely inappropriate
and she knows she's lying obviously when
she says this but she doubles down and
she says it's not photoshopped
i saw the tweet go out on a day that you
were trending so
she's lying so unfortunately for cardi
and the problem with having success is
that just because you're successful
doesn't mean you're smart
like she's gonna get sued owens later
took to instagram to address the whole
thing
in a 13-minute long video i am like you
know deeply protective over my family
um especially my brother who is a
completely
private citizen and has nothing to do
with cardi b
and her twerking and whopping and for
her to pretend that she knew
that this photoshop tweet was real and
was authentic um
she's gonna get sued for that plain and
simple i i don't play games with that
kind of stuff
but this isn't the first time the two
have come head to head
there are way more intellectual black
democrats you could have sat down with
that you
you chose an illiterate rapper because
that's what she's illiterate
back in september owens appeared on the
ben shapiro show and
threw some major shade at the rapper
following cardi's sit down with
then-presidential nominee
joe biden she asked pointedly ridiculous
questions
i want lower taxes but i want universal
health care for all
she had no idea what she was doing and
yet both bernie sanders
and joe biden made the time to sit with
her because they believe black people
are stupid
and black people that thought yay that's
a win no it's on a win cardi fired back
with
several tweets writing in part quote i
don't want to argue with you candace
i really don't have the time i honestly
just feel sorry for you
that time owens responded with an
eight-minute long video on instagram
and cardi she clapped back on insta live
why wouldn't joe biden sit down with me
cardi b
i have millions of followers i could
also encourage
millions of followers to go vote and i
don't know what black men broke your
heart
that you hate your kind so much once the
dust seemingly settled
cardi reflected on the feud and tweeted
that she hates arguing with people
adding that she didn't even really know
how they started fighting in the first
place
as for owens she felt like she walked
away from the beef
victorious quote she is still tweeting
about me
i broke cardi b
you